fearsome rock faces and daunting drops
athletes pit their fingernails against
breathtaking climbing routes and the
toughest conditions that nature has to
offer
when the world's best Mountaineers take
one of those giddy heights of their
sights Paul Diffley is often there to
capture all the action on camera Diffley
runs the film production company ha
takes together with partner Chris
Prescott they've now made 11 veritable
cliffhangers with climbing you know
you're not just you know it's not like
other sports where you try to beat live
a team or beat the other individual it's
it's more of a personal journey of anhui
climbing you trying to improve yourself
and you're trying to you know your issue
against the rock you against the
elements I think because of that
climbing generates just some great
stories dumbarton Rock overlooks the
river clyde in scotland as a stronghold
had seen its fair share of battles over
the centuries and more recently some
epic struggles filmed by paul deeply
it's also the scene for his latest film
redemption James Pearson's quest to
redeem his reputation among fellow
climbers by scaling the rock without
assistance filming was a challenge in
itself Paul dickly used drone mounted
cameras but also got up close to the
action because there are no second takes
here just across the cladding so Hardy
when you're filming you can't ask the
climb to stop you have to be in the
right position at the right time and the
only way you can film it's really so be
happy on the rock with them to hang off
the rock with ropes and the best
position for filming climbing is kind of
above the climber looking down because
then you see the face you see the hands
and it because but the cross the rock
ends there the only way to do that is to
get above them and so we've done that
like using camera cranes and looking
back down long diffley has been an avid
climber himself since the age of 16 that
gives some vital insights into what his
protagonists face plus it keeps him in
shape for that exhausting camera work it
was that hobby that got him into filming
in the first place
so I still enjoy having climbing sir
it's a wonderful blend of the the mind
and the body could you have to focus
fully on the mind and you have to work
out the moves it's not just about
physical strength it was at Dumbarton
rock then he shot his first major film
it documented the first ever solo
conquest of the rock Scotsman Dave
MacLeod spent 18 months on his attempt
enduring a number of painful Falls the
specific route he establishes classed as
one of the toughest in the world a labor
of love with a happy ending the rock is
very special it says it's very dense
rock and it forms really tight little
hand holds tight footholds and it makes
the climbing incredibly hard and also
you know the main face here is quite
steep it's like 1520 degrees over so it
which makes it for some of the world's
hardest rock climbing e-11 named after
the rocks climbing grade one dich 13
awards he taught himself how to operate
a camera and edit while working as an IT
specialist but in 2006 he ditched
computers for climbing and made his
passion his profession
I just walked out left my shoes and my
clothes you know the desk and just never
came back and it was pretty rushed
because at the time I had no training in
filmmaking I've made a couple of films
but never won any awards and said he
never made any money so it was quite a
gamble but I was ready for a change that
gamble paid off and he's never looked
back or down he makes some of the
equipment himself such as this makeshift
bosun's chair fashioned from an old
skateboard his films are largely
low-budget affairs and he relies on
sponsorship for more ambitious
undertakings such as 2013's distilled
diplomates his living from the proceeds
of DVD sales & downloads
everybody has access to you know decent
cameras now decent software it's it's we
open that you know there's a lot of
competition out there a lot of people
are making films so it's trying to make
your film stand out make your production
values looks higher than everyone else's
and just before us we've always cost a
bit on story I think if you can tell a
story you can connect with an audience
emotionally and for a good story Paul
deeply can always come back to Dumbarton
rock the place he set out on his ascent
to reach the peak of his craft